well
the first time i talked to you on jerry
uh you were doing octo um
sober october and there's something in
your eyes
um like i think you've talked about that
you you know you exercise the demons out
essentially so you
exercise to get whatever the parts of
you that you don't like out
uh there is a dark there's a darkness in
you there like the
the competitiveness and the focus of
that person that was a scary time
in a lot of ways that sober october
thing because uh
my friends were all talking [ __ ] right
because we're competing against each
other and these fitness challenges and
you had uh one point poor
like you got a certain amount of points
per each minute that you went at 80
of your max heart rate and one day i got
1100 points
so i did seven hours on an elliptical
machine
watching the bathhouse scene from john
wick where he murders all those people
in the bathroom i watched it probably 50
times in a row
i went crazy i went crazy but i went
crazy in a weird way
where it brought me back to my um
my fighting days it was like the same
that person came out again i was like
well i didn't even know he was in there
it's like they're like
like like an assassin like a killer like
i felt
i felt like i felt like a
like a different person is it echoes of
like what mike tyson talked about
essentially like
the but no orgasm in their oceans
all the crazy [ __ ] that he was is there
is there that
is there a violent person in there oh
yeah yeah there's a lot of there's a lot
of violence in me for sure i don't know
if it's genetic or learned or
it's because during my formative years
from the time i was 15
until i was 22 all i did was fight that
was all i did that was all i did all i
did was train and compete
that's all i did that was my whole life
is it connected to
uh so you uh your mom and dad broke up
early on is it connected to
the dad at all i'm sure it's connected
to him
also because he was violent and it made
me feel very scared to be around him
but i also think um it's connected in
who he was as a human is transferred
into my dna
you know i think there's a certain
amount of i mean
i mean to be prejudiced against myself i
look like a violent person
you know if i didn't know me i'm just
even the way i'm built
not even just the working out bar just
the size of my hands and
like there's the width of my shoulders
like there's
most likely a lot of violence in my
history in my past and my ancestry
and i think um i think we minimized that
with people like so much of your
behavior like i
when i see my daughter have a one
daughter that's obsessive
in terms of like she wants to get really
good at things like could she and she'll
practice things all day long
and and it's 100 my personality
like she's me in a female form
but without the anger as much and
without the um
fear like she's you know loving
household and everything like that but
she has this intense obsession with
doing things and doing things really
well and getting better what's the point
we have to tell her to stop like stop
doing handsprings in the house stop stop
come on just sit down have dinner like
one more one more like she's just like
she's like she's psycho yeah um
and i think there's a lot of
behavior and personality and
a lot of these things are passed down
through genetics we don't really know
right we don't know how much of who you
are
genetically is learn behavior you know
nature and nurture we don't know if it's
learned behavior or whether or not it's
something that's intrinsically a part of
you because of
you know who your parents were i think
there's there's
certainly some genetic violence in me
there's something you channeled it
yeah you figured out is basically your
life is a
productive exploration of how to channel
that yes try
how to figure out how to get get that
monkey to sit down
and calm down there's another person in
there like this is a
calm rational kind
friendly person who just wants to laugh
and have fun and then there's that dude
who comes out when i did sober october
that guy's scary i don't like that guy
you